bonsoir blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france la
turquie soutient de l'azerbaïdjan est à
la fois artisan de la paix est ce que
c'est compatible bien être juge et
partie dans cette affaire elle a soutenu
beaucoup l'azerbaïdjan dans son conflit
avec l'arménie
elle a soutenu alors par les discours
extrêmement extrêmement vigoureux
extrêmement variées par l'armement par
aussi un soutien hôtel en termes d'état
majeur des officiers
vous avez travaillé avec les tablettes
amazon azéri et les drones ont fait
aussi beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup de
dégâts donc le laser badges ont sans
doute doit beaucoup dans cette affaire
au soutien au soutien du rck et la
turquie voulait aujourd'hui participer
naturellement à l'opération de maintien
de la paix
le porte parole du kremlin a dit qu' il
n'était pas question qu'il y ait des
soldats turcs sur la ligne de contrôle
mais qu'en revanche il pourrait y avoir
des officiels turcs dans la salle dans
le bâtiment de contrôle du cessez le feu
alors on en est un peu là aujourd'hui et
dans le fond le groupe de minsk qui se
tient en ce moment à moscou tombe bien
puisque ça permet à la russie de dire
mais le cadre vegas et le groupe de
minsk est un groupe établi par
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe et la turquie fait
partie d'ailleurs de ce groupe mais pas
de la coprésidence la présence et la
russie la france et les états unis donc
d'une certaine manière la turquie est un
peu remise à sa place pour ce qui est de
la gestion du du cessez le feu
paris appelle la russie à lever les
ambiguïtés lesquels exactement alors à
part la turquie ya évidemment d'autres
ambiguïté les deux mille soldats russes
ont commencé à prendre position
notamment pour assurer la sécurité la
liberté
circulation dans le corridor de latchine
qui assure la liaison entre l'arménie et
le leader unique à rabat et les les
troupes russes dont prendre position
progressivement sur l'ensemble des
lignes de cessez le feu et dans
l'ensemble des sept districts de la zone
tampon qui avait été conquise par
l'arménie en 94 et qui vont être remis
sous le contrôle de l'intervention aux
fourneaux qu'au fur et à mesure que les
troupes arméniennes se retire et bien
les troupes de maintien de la paix de la
russie pour s'installer et la question
qu'on se pose avec cet accord conclut
est ce la fin du conflit gelé au karam a
écouté peut-être au bout du compte parce
que si l'on regarde attentivement le
communiqué du 10 novembre l'accord donc
été conclu entre la russie l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
on constate que comme je le disais à
l'instant la russie garantit la liberté
de circulation dans le corridor de
latchine par exemple chine c'est le
cordon ombilical entre l'arménie et le
negroni karabakh et donc c'est une
garantie qui est donnée pour dix ans
probablement à l'arménie et puisque ce
contingent de maintien de la paix là
pour cinq ans renouvelables une fois
sauf des accords d'une des parties et
puis il ya un deuxième corridors et ça
c'est une nouveauté qui est instaurée
entre la première de nick hatch evans
qui appartient à l'azerbaïdjan mais qui
est de l'autre côté de l'arménie et par
conséquent ce corridor qui reliera ce
territoire d'une catch evans à l'arménie
va également être garanti la liberté de
circulation
il sera garanti par les gardes
frontières du fsb le fsb
c'est les services de sécurité interne à
la russie donc c'est tout à fait un
engagement très important et jusqu'à
présent lorsque les azéri voulait aller
au lit catch evans il devait passer par
une route
très compliqué très escarpée à
l'intérieur de l'iran et maintenant ils
pourront aller directement en passant
par le sud de l'arménie
c'est donc évidemment une concession
arménienne et c'est probablement
l'élément le plus important de l'accord
pour le développement économique de la
région
parce que cela veut dire que l'on pourra
aller directement de la mer caspienne à
la mer noire et que les turcs sont
évidemment sur ce passage adage beaucoup
d'importance à cela
est ce que ça veut dire que dans le fond
puisque les russes garantit le le
couloir de latchine corridor de latchine
pour accéder au nagorny karabakh
est ce que ça veut dire que pendant dix
ans le liant negara bague ne sera pas
menacé et bien oui je le crois
il irait il revient maintenant au groupe
de minsk de décider de son statut est ce
que c'est il ya trois solutions ou bien
on leur a carrément à l'arménie avec ce
couloir qui est le cordon ombilical ou
bien on en fait une région autonome de
l'azerbaïdjan ou bien on innove et on en
invente une eau souveraineté des deux
pays voisin sur le nagorny karabakh
soleil vient ni gandhi karabakh
c'est une région montagneuse où il y
avait un rôle conflit 150000 habitants
c'est donc très peu de choses sur le
plan économique mais c'est une région
hautement symbolique pour un pays comme
pour l'eau merci beaucoup à cause
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales d'avoir apporté votre
éclairage